évidemment de l'impact de à new york
c'est une impact énorme également sur
les politiques et rongeurs des états
unis ont fermé la frontière presque avec
lui le mexique puis aux et possiblement
ou avec les canadiens alors qu'on avait
rien à faire à [ __ ] là-dedans et donc
les politiciens américains sont assez
mia le dha j'en vois pas la possibilité
énorme de libéraliser non seulement nos
frontières mais notre commerce avec et
biens et services et des personnes
et je déplore également ce qu'on
appellera du réaction entre le canada et
le mexique a pas de raison soir de fonds
il faut quand même penser dépenses sur
certaines choses
j'encouragerais le gouvernement canadien
d'ouvrir ses portes durant vers
l'amérique latine
on commence à voir le mexique et la
réaction inverse formidable pour nous
tous écoutez j'ai vu une étude de
goldman sachs qui disait que dans
l'année 2050 quand même cascade apporte
le mexique soit ou cinquième économie du
monde est probablement à 175 millions de
citoyens et puis
une économie qui voit deux parties de
passer de largement les grands pays de
l'europe et doré et de cavada bien sûr
oui mais on a une relation privilégiée
avec les mexicains aujourd'hui et avec
l'amérique la sienne aujourd'hui
alors il faut foncer dans le tas et pour
ceux évidemment il faut faire la part
des choses et puis d'arrêter d'être trop
prétentieux ou qu'on arrête le pétage de
bretelles et qu'on encourage les
mexicains à leur commerce avec nous et
leur collaboration féconde
j'ai vu le commentaire d'un ambassadeur
et ça c'est c'est eh oui et je pense que
le gouvernement du canada et le
gouvernement du mexique bien sûr ont
toutes les raisons au monde de civiliser
s'être aidé à sion parce que normalement
c'est nos alliés et nos amis et en aux
autres
il faut se servir des mexicains leur
collaboration
justement pour notre lancement en
amérique latine